cela fait deux ans que assia nourine et
ça aux scènes peuvent fouler la piste et
pratiquer leur passion grâce à la
fondation gouesnac'h us et l'association
chante l'ouvèze fraternité pour
l'égalité des chances une soixantaine de
jeunes accèdent à des sports comme le
golf le tennis et l'équitation moi je
suis
d'abord une habitante de champions
league depuis 31 ans mère célibataire
avec trois enfants trois garçons je
connais un peu la situation des enfants
des quartiers il y avait un besoin
al'approche signalé vers six jeunes là
il d'en parler d'autre chose et il
sortir aussi 2 2 lors de leur domaine de
leur quartier quoi et de ramener son
autre chose qui me connaissent pas c'est
ça l'idée en fait c'est les activités
sportives sont essentiels au
développement et à l'épanouissement de
l'enfant elle peut parfois coûter très
cher alors pour que la pratique sportive
soit équitable la fondation guen à russe
soutient financièrement les familles
moss personnellement c'était mon rêve de
faire l'équitation et c'était très cher
donc avant je pouvais pas on a fait une
année la dixième année on pouvait pas
mais j'ai quand même fait et j'aime
beaucoup le contact avec le cheval qu'on
a quand le brosse qu'on est sur son dos
qui l'a l'écoutent ouais elle a entré
les traits compta et contre tous les
contours les très très content à l'adema
moi j'ai passé ma vie avec les
chauffeurs outre les acquis sportif
l'équitation permet également aux jeunes
de sortir de leur zone de confort et
d'évoluer au sein de la société mois
l'évolution je la vois surtout sur leur
comportement
le
leur leurs acquis techniques c'est autre
chose mais c'est surtout leur
comportement parce que certains enfants
n'ont pas de cadre familial alors
certains sont bien cadré d'autres ne
sont pas assez cadré donc on arrive ici
nous fait un peu la police et un petit
peu géré on fait un peu office
d'éducateurs quoi de plus en plus
l'association freq ouvre son champ de
compétences à des activités culturelles
comme des ateliers d'arts plastiques de
théâtre ou encore de chant elle anime
également des cours pour apprendre le
français et le numérique aux parents qui
le souhaitent